c'est un sport national en grande
bretagne pariez sur les résultats
sportifs les matchs de soccer les
courses de chevaux
mais ces jours ci c'est avec les
élections que les bookmakers font plus
d'argent tout comme les électeurs
britanniques
les parieurs sont indécis et les défis
qu il est extrêmement difficile de
prévoir l'issue du scrutin dit joe cole
et les conservateurs sont favoris pour
nombre de sièges mais sans majorité tout
peut arriver
whitney houston à quelques heures des
élections les sondages donnent les deux
principaux partis au coude à coude
les conservateurs du premier ministre
sortant david cameron ni les
travaillistes ed miliband ne semble en
mesure d'obtenir les 326 sièges
nécessaires pour une majorité à la
chambre des communes
on aura probablement quelle que soit
l'issue quel que soit le vainqueur des
élections
ça c'est sur un gouvernement de
coalition et même seul le parti qui
remportera en termes de sièges genevois
à l'élection n'est pas assuré de former
le prochain gouvernement ça cette
historie dès le début de la campagne
les chefs des deux principales
formations politiques se sont fait voler
la vedette par ceux des tiers partis
dépassé sur sa droite par le parti
anti-européen you keep david cameron
s'est vue forcée de réitérer une
promesse lourde de conséquences un
référendum sur une éventuelle sortie de
l'union européenne je ne dirigerai pas
un gouvernement qui ne réalisera pas
cette promesse s'est juré son rival le
travailliste ed miliband à lui était
embarrassé tout au long de la campagne
par l'attitude à adopter face aux
indépendantistes écossais nicola
sturgeon
la charismatique leader du snp lui a
offert de former une coalition
mais répète ce qu'il a refusé pour ne
pas être accusé de soutenir un parti qui
souhaitent la fin du royaume uni seule
une décision que le travailliste
pourrait regretter au lendemain du
scrutin
à moins qu'il ne décide d'assouplir sa
position pour obtenir les clés du 10
downing street
jean-françois on arrive donc au terme
d'une campagne particulière extrêmement
serré
il peu probable que les britanniques et
un goût nouveau gouvernement demain soir
céline en fait il ya une chose qui
apparaît à peu près certaine c'est que
le résultat d'élections demain ne va pas
mettre fin au suspense tout au plus
va-t-il permettre de connaître de savoir
quel parti va obtenir quel nombre de
sièges à la chambre des communes mais ça
ne permettra pas de savoir qui va former
le prochain gouvernement pour ça il va
falloir attendre de longues tractations
pour ses devoirs qui est en mesure de
former une coalition des tractations qui
pourrait durer plusieurs jours voire
même plusieurs semaines et ça c'est une
question qui tient en haleine pas
seulement la grande bretagne mais en
fait l'europe toute entière parce qu'il
faut l'appeler s'il est reporté au
pouvoir le conservateur david cameron a
promis qu'il va tenir un référendum pour
permettre aux anglais de choisir s'il
souhaite ou non rester à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne mais ça évidemment
c'est une perspective qui inquiète
beaucoup
ici les milieux d'affaires en fait 2000
d'affaires européens évidemment si ces
aides mais les bennes qui lui est porté
au pouvoir mais cette question-là
devient caduque cette menace là est
écarté donc inutile de dire que si
jamais les travaillistes réussissent à
former une coalition
bah ya pas mal de monde un peu partout
en europe pouvant pousser un gros ouf de
soulagement
alors on se reparle de tout ça à peu
près à la même heure demain merci
beaucoup jean-françois vampire va